hey what's up guys it's Marcus Bradley
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD unboxing video and in this one I'll
be unboxing something from a fellow
youtuber from a giveaway I actually won
from youtube.com slash I bellick's or
David Bell he actually has a touch
channel of his own so I'll include the
link in the description he was actually
mentioned on the Engadget podcast and he
does a lot of tech related videos and
screencasts so he knows what he's
talking about so today I'm going to be
unboxing a small thing that I won from
his latest 300 subscriber giveaway so
let's just get right into this here we
go so here's the package so I guess
giving you a brief rundown of what I do
know to be in this package this is an
accessory to a product but I don't
actually own yet so I'm just gonna go
right on ahead and tell you guys that
this is likely going to be a giveaway
video in the near future
so stay tuned and if you watch this
whole video to get a taste of what
exactly they're going to be given away
so let's go right ahead and I open up
this little envelope here and see what
we get inside I guess it's not going to
be retail packaging since it is a
giveaway video not a purchase product
but it's worth taking a look so here it
is you probably get a little note here
and the actual accessory so this is an
accessory as you know the armband for
the iPod Nano latest version I'm gonna
take a look at the note here and I guess
I'll go ahead and say that this is from
Dave from the David Elcom so again I'll
have the links to its website and
everything in the description so you can
check it out so any of you guys out
there who do have an iPod Nano you want
to check out this case right here this
is the of obviously the Anna Nano
armband that will work with your latest
generation iPod Nano it has little
silicon case on the device itself with
the fake nano in it and the armband that
goes around your arm itself and I do
have skinny arms so it's probably not
going to fit me anyway so this is what
came in the box with the
bellick's giveaway so you do know that
when you enter one of his giveaways he
does do legitimate giveaways so you guys
can check out his videos at the link in
the description so thank you for
watching this quick unboxing video and
I'll talk to you guys in the next vid